merci monsieur le président merci à vous
pour ce discours est votre accueil
monsieur le président madame la ministre
l'oms et messieurs les parlementaires
madame la présidente de région
monsieur le maire mesdames et messieurs
merci monsieur le maire de nous
accueillir dans cette belle ville de
montpellier
j'ai cru comprendre qu'une fois par
siècle cette ville accueillait la
mutualité et que c'est le moment ce
n'est pas le seul où les présidents
viennent tôt devant et s'exprimer et il
y a un tout petit peu plus d'un siècle
c'est le président poincaré qui dans
cette même ville vous retrouvez preuve
s'il en était que votre mouvement est
enracinée dans l'histoire de la
république et a toujours eu ce lien si
particulier président que vous venez de
rap au justice sociale solidarité
dignité ce sont les engagements
républicains et vous venez à l'instant
de retracer dans quelques secteurs
fondamentaux sur quelques enjeux
essentiels de notre société
l'importance de ces engagements et de
ses valeurs bien sûr nous continuerons à
promettre à chaque française et à chaque
français leurs droits fondamentaux
bien sûr nous continuerons à faire
fonctionner un système de protection
sociale qui donne à la solidarité une
dimension universelle
mais dans les faits ce que nous
constatons c'est que tous les jours
l'effectivité de ces droits est remise
en cause
tous les jours nombre de nos concitoyens
constatent que
universalité et mité d'exception de
disparités d'un parce que les situations
où les droits promis ne sont pas des
droits réels et ils le découvrent trop
tard lorsque l'urgence est là lorsque la
détresse et là au moment où il aurait
besoin d'un socle de solidarité
nationale solide ils le sentent parfois
trop souvent se dérober sous leurs pieds
nous vivons dans un pays où la promesse
républicaine est ainsi trop souvent
déçus parce que nous avons maintenu les
droits formels sans nous soucier assez
de fer qu'ils soient des droits réels
pour chacun à l'école dans le monde du
travail dans le monde de la santé
les français sont viscéralement attachés
à des droits mais il constate trop
souvent que pour beaucoup il n'existe
que sur le papier est plus dans les
faits c'est ça l'indignation française
contemporaine
pourtant et c'est un vrai paradoxe nous
consacrons une part toujours plus grande
de notre richesse nationale à la
protection sociale
alors oui nous pouvons être fiers de
notre système de protection sociale ils
nous honorent et il a à travers les
décennies répondu à ces indignations les
mêmes je me fais à l'instant l'écho mais
il nous reste il nous aurait en quelque
sorte dispenser d'un effort plus
exigeants encore celui de regarder la
réalité de notre société en face
l'effectivité de chacun des droits les
plis de la société les part obscure
maudite où ces droits promis sont perdus
ou ses droits formels ne sont plus
réalité
une société qui sécrètent toujours plus
d'inégalités de destin de parcours
d'opportunités une société qui exclut
sans possibilité de recours
des pans entiers de notre population une
société qui ne peut pas uniquement
racheter cette faillite politique et
morale par de la redistribution
monétaire forcément toujours
insuffisante et c'est le malentendu que
je voudrais commencer par lever ce matin
avec vous
j'entendais beaucoup de commentateurs
dire il va aller devant les mutuelles il
va faire un grand tournant social mais
moi je vais vous dire je n'ai pas le
sentiment que lorsqu on redresse
l'économie
lorsqu'on permet à des gens d'y produire
davantage on ne soit contre le modèle
social vous en est un exemple vivant
mais c'est produire pour pouvoir
redistribuer
je n'ai pas le sentiment que quand on
fait les réformes de l'école du collège
du lycée de l'université fait depuis un
peu plus d'un an on soit l'ennemi de la
justice mais on s'attaque à la racine du
mal le fait que nous nous sommes depuis
des décennies contenter des droits
formels de la redistribution strictement
monétaire oubliant les inégalités de
destin notre système aujourd'hui est
plus inégale qu'il ya trente ans sur le
plan scolaire sur le plan de l'accès aux
emplois les plus qualifiés qu'il
s'agisse de l'entreprise ou de la haute
fonction publique
notre système est plus déterministe
qu'il ya 30 ans c'est une réalité et
donc s'attaquer aux inégalités c'est
s'attaquer à leurs racines c'est vouloir
bousculer une société devenue société de
statut c'est vouloir reconnaître que
tous ces défis ne sont pas simplement
monétaire c'est vouloir en quelque sorte
réinventer mais vous me siffle rey à la
fin si vous le souhaitez mais
laissez-moi terminée d'autant que je ne
vous aperçoit pas
et c'est savoir réinventer notre état
providence
celui ci n'offrent trop souvent que le
dernier filet de protection
indispensable et que nous maintiendrons
mais il ne garantit pas suffisamment les
conditions d'une vie digne
c'est cela le combat que je veux pour ce
quinquennat une vie digne et une vie
digne
ça ne veut pas dire promettre de rester
là où on est né
là où on est tombé ça veut dire pouvoir
choisir à chaque instant on le peut sa
fille et ça veut dire avoir une société
qui vous donne les conditions de cette
dignité
nous avons héritées du 20e siècle un
état providence de l'assurance et nous
devons le conforter mais nous devons
bâtir pour le 21e siècle un état
providence de la dignité de
l'émancipation et il nous faut une
organisation collective de fraternité
qui assure la dignité de chacun c'est là
mon objectif principal c'est celui de
l'état mais vous avez parfaitement
raison il ne le peut pas seul c'est
celui des collectivités territoriales
qui toutes sont engagés dans cette
action
région département métropole commune
c'est le travail des partenaires sociaux
au contact du réel du social
chaque jour et c'est celui de l'ensemble
des acteurs sociaux et de ses acteurs un
peu particulier dont vous avez rappelé
l'histoire et la force que sont en effet
les mutualistes acteurs de la solidarité
nationale engagés de cette cause qui
vous l'avez rappelé tout à la fois
protège et agissent on construit à
travers les siècles
cette capacité à apporter des réponses
en termes de protection mais aussi à
agir sur le terrain à offrir du soin de
la tension et je n'oublierai pas dans
des temps autres les heures passent et
non loin de lorient à kerpape voyant ce
travail qui avait été fait et
l'excellence justement de celui ci mais
c'est aussi l'engagement le temps de mes
bénévolement dans des conseils et dans
l'action de terrain pour changer c'est
la participation de votre mouvement au
projet républicain qui permettra avec
l'ensemble des acteurs que j'ai cités
cette refondation radicale dont nous
avons au bout aujourd'hui besoin
notre choix est simple c'est le choix
entre
en quelque sorte de fidélité soit nous
restons fidèles à un système qui
n'atteint plus les objectifs de justice
sociale qu'ils s'étaient origène
originellement assigné est inné de
surcroît plus conformes aux attentes de
nos concitoyens ni des acteurs qui le
font soit nous choisissons ensemble
d'être fidèle aux valeurs qui nous
unissent pour réinventer un système qui
rendent les droits effectif et concret
pour tous nos concitoyens
c'est cette deuxième voie avec vous que
je veux choisir lé plus difficultueuse
elle prend sans doute plus de temps
elle ne se règle pas simplement par des
promesses budgétaires ou des engagements
qui seront pas retenus elle n'implique
notre action immédiate et elle nous
invite collectivement à ne céder ni au
cynisme ni à l'hypocrisie la part la
plus précieuse de notre système social
c'est l'esprit qui l'a fait naître
c'est cette solidarité visionnaire des
membres du conseil national de la
résistance qui ont inventé le système
convenant parfaitement à un peuple
meurtri et à une nation en
reconstruction
notre mission c'est de renouer avec cet
esprit de ne pas avoir peur des
changements car la société a changé et
non de nous faire les vestales d'un
ordonnancement social que depuis 25 ans
l'évolution du monde des moeurs de la
société est venue ébranler sur ses bases
et dont il est venue saper l'efficacité
nous pourrions nous aussi après tant
d'autres cd à l'adoration des totems
mais je préférerai toujours la justice
sociale effective aux incantations et
l'efficacité au fétichisme
c'est pourquoi ce que nous devons faire
en matière de solidarité nationale c'est
une révolution profonde qui rendent aux
français leurs droits leur dignité leur
espérance et je la résume ray autour de
trois principes la prévention qui
attaquent les inégalités avant qu'il ne
soit trop tard
car c'est tout à la fois plus efficace
et plus juste
l'universalité qui donne les mêmes
droits à chacun de manière transparente
parce que c'est le seul moyen de rebâtir
la confiance dans notre système led
imité par led l'accompagnement la
présence le travail comme clé de
l'émancipation
pour toutes celles et ceux qui peuvent y
avoir accès car c'est ce qui permet à
chacun de véritablement construire sa
vie
la solution n'est pas de dépenser
toujours plus d'argent ou de considérer
qu'il y aurait d'un côté ceux qui
croient dans la transformation sociale
et qui alignerait les lignes de crédit
et ceux qui n'y croient pas et qui
serait forcément pour en réduire les
dépenses
d'abord une mauvaise nouvelle les
dépenses sociales
vous les payez nous les payons et trop
souvent notre pays nous considérons que
lorsque c'est l'état se serait l'autre
c'est nous pire encore il se peut que ce
soit nos enfants lorsque c'est du
déficit accumulé qui devient de la dette
la question est de regarder en face
trois grands défis sur lesquels je
voudrais revenir m'inscrivant en quelque
sorte dans vos pas essayé à l'aune des
trois principes que je viens d'évoquer
d'apporter quelques réponses
la santé l'âge et l'exclusion
sur la santé les choses ont été
profondément bouleversé durant les
décennies qui viennent de s'écouler
notre système est en crise mais il ne
l'est pas d'hier l'impatience est là et
elle est légitime
la souffrance est au quotidien pour des
femmes et des hommes qui chaque jour
s'occupe de ceux qui ne peuvent attendre
de ceux qui souffrent et de ce qu'ils
appellent une réponse immédiate et si
nous regardons en face notre système de
santé
il soigne bien et nous devons en être
fiers
il est efficace quand on le compare aux
autres grands systèmes
mais il prévient mal beaucoup moins bien
que les autres
c'est sans doute sa première
caractéristique or si nous prévenons mal
nous laissons nos concitoyens aller vers
des pathologies plus lourdes et donc
plus coûteuse parfois s'exclure de la
société avoir un système qui prévient
mieux et tout à la fois préférable sur
le plan de la santé collective et de
l'efficacité de notre système
c'est ce que la politique menée depuis
plusieurs années par nos prédécesseurs
poursuivi et intensifié par le
gouvernement par exemple en matière de
tabac est en train de permettre de faire
avec des premiers résultats qui
progressivement donneront dans le temps
leur efficacité politique de prévention
est une des clés pour répondre à ce défi
contemporain si nous regardons la
deuxième caractéristique de notre
système
je ne veux pas être exhaustif mais
essayez partouche d'en souligner les
imperfections vous l'avez parfaitement
décrite c'est la trop grande
renonciation aux soins pour des raisons
géographiques pour des raisons
monétaires ou de complexité ou pour des
raisons sociales liées à la
stigmatisation
je ne détaillerai pas ce point vous
l'avez parfaitement décrit et je me
retrouve pleinement dans le constat que
vous avez pu en faire le troisième
élément c'est sans doute essai
en quelque sorte le symptôme jumeau du
manque de prévention le trop grand
nombre d'actes inutiles la
surmédicalisation parce que lorsqu'on
arrive trop tard ou dans un système qui
est parfois devenu trop aveugle
on fait trop d'actes et lorsqu'on est
dans un système dans les incitations ne
sont pas les bonnes parce qu'il tarifie
à l'activité ou à l'acte de manière trop
systématique et bien si nous nous
comparons nous avons un système en effet
de santé où il ya plus d'actes inutiles
ou de surmédication que chez nombre de
nos voisins
est-ce que c'est mieux pour nos
concitoyens et ce qu'on protège lui est
ce qu'on soigne mieux avec cela non
est-ce que c'est plus coûteux oui vous
voyez là que essayer de faire des
économies n'est pas forcément réduire la
qualité de la réponse apportée
parce que nous avons trop souvent et
longtemps répondu à des problématiques
de qualité par de la quantité d'actes ça
n'était pas la bonne réponse
3il quatrième constat que nous pourrions
faire c'est que les pathologies ont
changé notre système de santé était
formidablement adapté à des systèmes où
il fallait très bien soigner des
maladies et du complexe et il a été fait
pour ça et l'excellence d'ailleurs de
notre système en particulier du système
hospitalier
la qualité de notre médecine et en
particulier notre médecine spécialisée
c'est tout entier dirigé en ce sens et
ça a été l'excellence et c'est toujours
l'excellence de la clinique de la
recherche et du soin français mais de
plus en plus notre système de soins a à
traiter de maladies chroniques de
pathologies liées en effet à la fois au
vieillissement et aux transformations
sociétales de santé collectif or la
réponse est différente et c'est un
parcours un accompagnement dans la durée
et pas simplement une série d'actes
isolés
enfin les professionnels ont changé et
les choix collectifs ne sont plus les
mêmes
ce qui a créé en effet une organisation
différente sur le territoire aujourd'hui
les jeunes françaises et français qui
embrasse la carrière de médecin non plus
on voit envie d'avoir la vie de leurs
parents
les systèmes de garde ne sont plus les
mêmes la continuité des soins sur le
territoire n'est plus assurée de la même
façon parce que c'est un aussi un choix
qui fait parce que la société a changé
il nous faut savoir répondre à ces
aspirations collectivement en organisant
différemment les soins en tout cas en
répondant aux problématiques que nous
posent ces transformations
notre système est un système
d'excellence mais il a été bousculé par
ces transformations ces défis que je
viens d'évoquer
et il est aujourd'hui tiraillé des
déserts médicaux à des pathologies mal
couvertes à une dépense qui ne répond
plus toujours à la qualité requise et à
un système hospitalier qui souffrent
parce qu'il devient en particulier les
urgences
celui qui prend en quelque sorte sur lui
toutes les tensions existantes du
système comme vous l'avez décrit en
parlant de l'accès aux urgences
le deuxième défi qui est le nôtre c'est
celui de l'âge vous avez je n'y
reviendrai pas parfaitement décrit l'une
de nos réussites collectives
la réussite de nos économies et sociétés
développées nous vivons plus vieux et
nous vivons aussi pluvieux en bonne
santé
cela pose évidemment plusieurs questions
à notre organisation collective qu'il ne
faut pas méconnaître le système de
retraite
peut-il être totalement inchangés dans
une société qui continue ainsi à
vieillir et où donc l'espérance de vie
et nous devons nous en réjouir dans le
temps d'après la vie actif tel que nous
l'avons pensé jusque là s'allonge ou le
temps aussi des études s'est allongée
avant la vie active la chronologie de
nos vies n'est plus
il ya 20 ou 30 ans le temps des études
s'est allongé le temps du
réapprentissage tout au long de la vie
est en train de s'installer et la durée
de la retraite s'allonge aussi
or nous dépensons beaucoup pour notre
système de retraite souvent plus que nos
voisins mais nous n'avons malgré toutes
les réformes de nos prédécesseurs pas
réussi à installer totalement la
viabilité de ce système dans la durée et
surtout pas réussi à reconstruire la
confiance de nos concitoyens dans la
durée une très large majorité des plus
jeunes qui rentrent dans la vie active
pense qu'ils n'auront pas de retraite
que leurs retraites ne sera pas assurée
par un système de solidarité
intergénérationnelle ce système de
redistribution auquel je tiens et qui
sera maintenu
parce que la défiance s'est installée la
défiance est aussi installée parce que
nous avons quarante deux régimes qui par
sédimentation construit les petites
différences et avec elle les petites
inégalités qui ont plus à voir leur
justification mais l'antenne encore la
plupart du temps non parce qu'elles ont
répondu à une société de statut mais non
plus quand elles ne correspondent plus
aux défis contemporains
or vous l'avais dit il ya encore des
vraies inégalités devant le grand âge
mais bien souvent elles ne vont pas avec
les statuts ou les régimes de retraite
parce qu'elles correspondent à des
situations assez particulières
individuelles liées aux accidents de la
vie à l'exposition à certains risques
que chacun inconnue et non pas au statut
qu'il a épousée à un moment de sa vie et
dont il changera pour la génération qui
advient aujourd'hui à la fille actifs et
donc ce système qui s'est
progressivement conçu dans le temps et
qui répondait aux défis d'une société
d'après guerre industrielle de cycle
long n'est plus adapté à une société qui
vieillit ou les parcours sont de plus en
plus heurté
on les parcours sont de plus en plus
individualisée et où les inégalités sont
devenus statutaires et notre capacité à
y répondre
sera la condition de la confiance
collective dans le système mais le
vieillissement de notre population
soulève un deuxième défi vous l'avez
parfaitement évoqué celui plus grand âge
de la dépendance sujet qui tout à la
fois nous bouleverse et que beaucoup
d'entre nous voudrait tenir à l'écart
notre société ne veut plus voir à la
fois la grande vulnérabilité mais aussi
la place de la mort qui à un moment de
ce chemin arrive cela dit beaucoup de
nous et je ne m'étendrai pas sur ce
point
aujourd'hui je serais et sinon trop long
mais la dépendance est là et ce nouvel
âge vulnérables de la vie est en train
de s'installer ne pas le voir ou
considéré que ce serait la sphère de
quelques-uns c'est ne pas nous traiter
dignement nous mêmes c'est ne pas
traiter dignement les femmes et les
hommes qui une fois encore ont la charge
au quotidien de femmes et d'hommes qui
vivent parfois leurs dernières heures
leurs dernières semaines et dont ils
sont celles et ceux qui les soignent
bien souvent la dernière famille le
train capacité aujourd'hui à répondre à
ce défi a construit de la souffrance
sociale dans les ehpad chez les
personnes dépendantes ou pour leurs
familles nous devons regarder cela en
face c'est un échec collectif et je le
porte de là où je suis avec la seule
unité qui doit être la mienne nous ne le
résoudrons pas du jour au lendemain mais
nous devons en face
regardez cette société qui change
l'appréhender et considérer que notre
réponse n'est pas à la bonne hauteur en
termes de solidarité collective et que
parce que
nos concitoyens les plus âgés rentre de
plus en plus tard dans les ehpad ou dans
les établissements
ils ont aussi de plus en plus tôt besoin
de soins et que ces établissements qu'on
avait créé pour accompagner un moment de
la vie où on ne pouvait plus rester dans
la famille sont en train de se
transformer et de devenir des lieux où
on a aussi besoin d'un soin apporté
d'une médicalisation qui n'existent pas
partout ou pas suffisamment
et donc pour lesquelles notre réponse
doit être différente et sur laquelle il
nous faut penser une réorganisation
collective le troisième défi qui nous
est porté c'est celui de l'exclusion
si nous ne regardons pas nos concitoyens
les plus pauvres si nous ne regardons
pas cette part de la société
quelle nation sommes nous on m'a souvent
reproché de n'être que pour les
métropoles pardon pour montpellier que
pour cette france qui réussit que pour
les gens formidables etc
oui je veux les encourager parce que si
je n'y arrive pas il n'y a pas de chance
que le reste de la société puisse en
sortir
je vous le confirme et donc je veux que
celles et ceux qui peuvent produire
réussir embauché le fasse encore
davantage parce que je regarde partout
autour de nous et le fait de mettre un
plafond à la réussite n'a jamais réglé
le problème de l'exclusion
mais je le dis je le répète et je
continuerai un inlassable le mans à le
faire quand ceux qui réussissent ne
veulent pas regarder ceux qui sont
laissés au bord du chemin
dans quelle société veulent t'ils vivre
qui regardent autour d'eux les extrêmes
monter les discours de haine embrasé nos
démocraties c'est le fruit de ses
égoïsmes et de cet aveuglement et donc
nous devons tout en faisant de notre
économie une économie plus forte plus
productifs tout en étant les promoteurs
assumé d'une innovation d'une force
économique revitaliser vouloir aussi
répondre à la problématique de la
pauvreté de l'exclusion dans notre
société
et là aussi regardons la réalité en face
nous avons ces dernières décennies
dépenser de plus en plus sur ce sujet et
avons-nous régler le problème non
l'avons nous mieux prévenu
non avons-nous changer les trajectoires
permis aux gens de s'en sortir davantage
non avons-nous mieux accompagner
rarement quand je regarde aujourd'hui
les chiffres la réalité
nous avons des dispositifs qui sont là
nombreux mais les enfants qui naissent
dans la pauvreté ils restent encore trop
souvent et le déterminisme s'est
installée aujourd'hui le visage de la
pauvreté qu'elle est il un enfant sur
cinq
une famille monoparentale sur trois le
visage de la pauvreté il est plurielle
il est divers ça n'est pas un grand tout
dans lesquels dans lequel on pourrait en
quelque sorte inclure une part statique
de la société qui est la nôtre nous
avons créé un système qui s'est
progressivement pour ce qui est de
l'état déshumanisé on a pensé que la
réponse à l'exclusion à la pauvreté
c'était de l'argent nous avons ces dix
dernières années augmenté le rsa de 80%
mais nous avons baissé l'accompagnement
de 40% en termes de dépenses ce chiffre
du tout
nous avons aujourd'hui 50 % de celles et
ceux qui sont au rsa qui après quatre
années sont toujours au rsa nous avons
30% de femmes et d'hommes qui n'ont pas
qu'ils ne vont pas vers les prestations
qui leur sont promises
parce qu'elles sont trop complexes ou
stigmatisante et donc nous avons un
système qui prévient mal qui stigmatise
encore est trop complexe qui est peu
humain et qui ne permet pas à celles et
ceux qui tombent qui tombe dans ces
situations d'exclusion ou de pauvreté de
s'en sortir au plus vite de retrouver
toute leur place dans la société
et là aussi nous devons avec toute la
dureté du constat que je fais je le fais
au premier chef
pour moi ce constat je le fais pour nous
je ne le fais pas pour celles et ceux
qui sont dans ces situations parce
qu'ils en sont les premières victimes
parce qu'on ne choisit pas ses
situations mais si nous nous ne
regardons pas en face la réalité qui est
la nôtre et les échecs de notre action
comment y apporter une réponse sur ces
trois grands défis la santé le
vieillissement et l'exclusion
nous en sommes là alors la solution est
de s'attaquer à mes yeux aux problèmes à
la racine aux dysfonctionnements d'un
système social trop centrée sur les
acteurs et pas assez sur nos
compatriotes à avoir plus de prévention
plus d'accompagnement plus de
responsabilité collective de chacun
d'entre nous est d'essayer d'apporter
par une transformation profonde qui
prendra du temps qui est peut-être moins
sidérante que de l'argent mis sur la
table mais j'en suis sûr
beaucoup plus efficace parce qu'elle ira
avec de l'investissement dans certaines
politiques publiques est en effet de la
dépense que nous allons assumer mais
aussi de la transformation et des
économies qu'il faudra savoir faire sur
les parts inutile des dépenses que je
viens de décrire cette transformation
collective je veux que nous la menue
ensemble sur les trois défis que je
viens d'évoquer sur la santé avant tout
nous affichons un reste à charge totale
sur des dépenses de santé d'environ huit
et demi pour cent mais quelle est la
réalité de ce système pour ceux qui ont
un peu moins d'argent
un peu moins d'accès aux praticiens un
peu moins d'habitude aussi de consulter
régulièrement et sur des prestations de
base qui font la vie du quotidien
quelle est la réalité du système si on
veut qu'il prévienne mieux et qu'il
soigne mieux au plus près du terrain et
ont plutôt des réalités c'est que le
reste à charge pour les prothèses
dentaires est aujourd'hui en moyenne de
43 % ce qui veut dire en moyenne 200
euros pour une couronne
il est de 22% sur l'optique ce qui est
en moyenne même si les différences sont
très importantes dans son secteur de 65
euros pour la correction d'une youpi il
est de 53% sur les audioprothèses
c'est-à-dire 1700 euros en moyenne pour
être équipés je parle là du reste à
charge
cela veut dire que nombre de nos
concitoyens présentant des pathologies
simples doivent renoncer à se soigner
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire très
concrètement parce que nous mettons nos
maux qui sont parfois un peu technique
ça veut dire que la possibilité de
sourire de voir d'entendre de manger
parfois normalement nos concitoyens qui
à cause du reste à charge n'ont pas
accès à ces prothèses en sont privés ça
veut dire que
derrière ce sont des enfants qui
n'arrive pas à lire à l'école comme il
se doit puisque en effet la capacité à
être équipés de lunettes est l'une des
premières causes du mauvais
apprentissage et de l'illettrisme en fin
de primaire ça veut dire que certains de
nos concitoyens qui sont exclus du
travail n'arrivent pas à y revenir parce
qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens de soigner
leurs dents ou parce qu'ils n'ont pas
les moyens de corriger de corriger une
audition devenu défectueuse ça veut dire
que nos concitoyens les plus âgés
lorsqu'il commence à perdre l'audition
et qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens de le
corriger tomberont plus rapidement dans
la grande dépendance pardon d'être
concret mais c'est cela est derrière ce
que je décris de situations concrètes
qui sont plus prosaïques que des mots
qui parfois protège de la réalité ce
sont à chaque fois des drames
individuels
c'est cette inégalité de trajectoire
dont je vous parlais ça ne paraît rien
mais au bout de quelques temps cela
devient irrattrapable donc oui nous
devons intervenir tout au plus vite plus
massivement
c'est la meilleure façon de lutter
contre les inégalités et c'est ce que
nous avons réussi avec le reste à charge
0 ou le 100% santé la transformation
profonde que nous avons entreprise sera
certainement présenté d'abord sous son
aspect financier
il est réel et il est évident que
permettre à tous ceux qui jusqu'ici ne
pouvait pour des raisons monétaires
bénéficier des soins auditifs dentaires
ou optiques
c'est une conquête sociale essentielle
et c'est un investissement que j'assume
un investissement que nous allons
partager ensemble et qui va permettre de
réduire ce reste à charge à 0
rassurez vous
allez-y baisser les taux alors attendez
je vais y venir je vais gérer ce prix
une méthode ça fait les taxes sur le
secteur mutualiste
allez-y oui je n'ai pas entendu les
taxes sur
donc pour que tout le monde soit au
clair je prends que les deux
interpellations sont convergentes c'est
la proposition de revenir sur la
fiscalité du secteur pour lui permettre
d'avancer d'investir davantage
[Applaudissements]
je vais parfaitement clair l'accord
construit grâce à l'implication de tous
et je veux vraiment vous en remercier et
par le travail et l'engagement de la
ministre est indépendant de ces mesures
donc si nous allions dans ce sens je
vous demanderai davantage mais je suis
prêt à ouvrir cette discussion
mais je ne voudrais pas qu entre nous il
y un malentendu c'est que l'accord
obtenu n'est pas sujet à une réforme de
la fiscalité du secteur maintenant je
suis tout à fait prêt à ouvrir une
discussion sur la fiscalité du secteur
pour qu'ensemble nous puissions faire
davantage et être plus efficace dans
l'engagement de celui ci et ça vous
m'aurez toujours à vos côtés
s'il faut aller dans un système de bon
sens sur lequel vous m'interpeller je
reviens
[Applaudissements]
mais je ne voudrais pas qu ans par ce
dialogue improvisé nous tombions dans
les travers que je dénonçais où l'état
discuterait avec le secteur mutualiste
en oubliant que derrière ce sont nos
concitoyens et leurs intérêts revenons
donc à nos prothèse dentaire optique et
auditive et à leur remboursement
la logique qui est derrière cette
avancée fondamentale est là je le disais
un caractère monétaire mais elle repose
d'abord sur un recours accru aux soins
il s'agit ainsi de prévenir que les
pathologies concernées ne devienne plus
grave plus handicapante et pour cela il
s'agit de renforcer considérablement la
prévention notamment chez les plus
jeunes avec des dépistages systématiques
et c'est ça pour moi ce que vous avez
collectivement réussi à négocier ces
derniers mois et qui est essentiel nous
mettrons en place un dépistage des
troubles visuels et auditifs renforcer
au plus jeune âge avec trois nouvelles
consultation du médecin traitant ou
scolaires pour diminuer le recours aux
soins prothétiques dentaire nous
instaurons un examen pour les enfants de
3 ans mais aussi pour les jeunes de 24
ans c'est ça la prévention c'est de
s'assurer qu'au plus tôt pour nos
concitoyens il y à l'accès à la
consultation qui permet de voir s'il y a
un besoin de soins ou s'il y a des
comportements inchangé et cela fait
partie de l'accord et cela aussi est
intéressant dans les mutuelles pour les
professionnels pour l'état parce qu'en
instaurant ces consultations plus tôt
nous prévenons mieux et donc nous
dépenserons - cette prévention elle va
aussi avec une responsabilisation de
l'ensemble des professionnels et une
revalorisation de certains actes c'est
ça la cohérence sur laquelle je veux ici
insiste et de l'accord qui a été obtenu
par exemple pour les dentistes le fait
de revaloriser fortement les soins
conservateurs parce que aujourd'hui les
professionnels n'étaient pas dignement
payer sur ses soins là oui il faisait
essentiellement leurs revenus ce qui
était légitime
sur des axes des actes plus tardif et
plus coûteux pour nos concitoyens comme
pour la collectivité mais il faut aussi
est responsable nous voulons des
dentistes qui puissent bien vivre de
leur métier qu'ils puissent continuer à
s'installer et donc le choix
collectivement qui est fait de mieux
rembourser les soins conservateurs va
dans ce sens et permet aussi d'avoir une
approche sur le curatif beaucoup plus
cohérente
l'autre part de la révolution de la
prévention reposera sur un accès
facilité aux professionnels de santé
car le remboursement intégral des
lunettes essentiel ne sert à rien si
l'on met douze mois à avoir un rendez
vous avec un ophtalmologiste et donc
pour cela nous irons plus loin dans
l'organisation des coopérations
professionnelle la profession
d'assistant dentaire sera étendu nous
irons plus loin dans la formation des
opticiens et augmenteront le nombre
d'audioprothésiste c'est un ensemble de
l'organisation des professions vers
lequel nous devons aller
mais ce que je veux ici vous faire
toucher du doigt à travers cette réforme
c'est que nous allons par l'engagement
collectif par l'illustration de ce que
vous appelez de vos voeux monsieur le
président c'est à dire l'engagement de
l'état l'engagement des mutuelles des
assureurs de l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé et de ceux qui
en assure justement la protection
l'engagement des partenaires sociaux et
de l'assurance maladie
nous avons trouvé une solution
intelligente qui permet d'une part de
d'avoir une réponse en terme de pouvoir
d'achat ça on va passer de 1700 euros à
0 2 200 euros à 0 2 65 euros à 0 donc ça
du pouvoir d'achat pour nos concitoyens
on va permettre une meilleure prévention
et on va permettre une organisation sur
ces trois professions du système de
soins beaucoup plus intelligente et qui
répondent aux défis que je viens de
décrire
et donc vous avez sur ces trois sujets
collectivement su apporter une réponse
au défi à l'impasse dans laquelle nous
étions jusque alors pouvoir d'achat
prévention meilleur service car
meilleure organisation collective du
soin nous avons pour cela comme je le
disais c'est pour cela que je souhaitais
aussi vous en remercier besoin de
l'engagement et de la responsabilité de
tous et vous êtes l'exemple
mesdames et messieurs sur le 100 % santé
de cet engagement
l'assurance maladie obligatoire
participera au financement de la réforme
en doublant sa prise en charge sur les
aides auditives pour les adultes d'ici
2022 mais aux côtés de l'assurance
maladie obligatoire
les organismes complémentaires que vous
représentez se sont aussi engagés à
prendre leur part dans la couverture de
ce panier 100% santé les contrats
complémentaires santé responsable qui
assure plus de 90 % des français devront
obligatoirement couvrir ce panier et
bien sûr cette réforme ne saurait
engendrait d'augmentation spécifique du
coût d'acquisition d'une complémentaire
santé pour les assurés c'est
l'engagement collectif que nous avons
pris et il n'y a pas dans cette affaire
de marché de dupes et j'ai vu les
polémiques naissantes
pas sûr
cet accord met sur le passé
l'augmentation de certaines
complémentaires
c'est l'engagement la responsabilité
collective des acteurs qui permet de
maîtriser les coûts ce que vous avez su
faire dans plusieurs secteurs c'est
aussi la transparence complète la
concurrence sainement organisé qui
permet d'éviter les pratiques dont les
premières victimes sont nos concitoyens
c'est votre engagement celui ci et je
vous en remercie et je compte sur vous
pour réussir ce défi pour être au rendez
vous que les français attendront
concrètement pour une pleine mise en
oeuvre sur les trois années qui viennent
puisque cette réforme sera finalisé
d'ici 2021 donc oui nous devons
intervenir plus tôt plus vite plus
massivement en nous mobilisant tous
c'est la meilleure de façon de lutter
contre les inégalités en matière de
santé que je rappeler tout à l'heure et
nous avons également investi
considérablement en la matière nous
sommes comme je le disais légitimement
fiers de notre système de santé de la
performance de nos hôpitaux
mais il y a aussi les situations d'échec
sur lesquels je revenais pour répondre à
ces défis nous devons aussi à la fois
pour l'hôpital pour l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé et pour nos
concitoyens qui ont recours à notre
système de santé
réussir à apporter une réponse plus
adaptée et à transformer notre modèle
historique
nous sommes face à des disparités
considérables à une inadaptation de ce
modèle orienté vers une approche
individuelle et curatif de soins aigus
comme je le disais alors que de nouveaux
besoins de prévention et soins au long
cours émergent avec les maladies
chroniques
avec le vieillissement si nous voulons
privilégier la qualité et la prévention
nous devons aussi au delà de ce premier
accord obtenu mener une réorientation de
l'organisation du dispositif de soins
afin de traiter les pathologies très en
amont
afin de repenser notre organisation
collective il nous faut passer
progressivement d'une logique de gestion
de l'offre de soins de cartographie trop
rigide d'une approche trop numérique et
budgétaires à une logique de demandes
fondées sur les services à rendre à la
population sur le territoire sur leur
bassin de vie et une logique plus
individus et et individualisé c'est à
dire tourner vers le patient pour
répondre à ces besoins de soins de
proximité
les acteurs doivent s'organiser en
réseau décloisonner la médecine de ville
et l'hôpital garantissant ainsi l'accès
à 5 service au minimum accès à un
médecin traitant
permanence des soins aient accès aux
soins non programmés continuité des
soins gradation des soins dépistage et
vaccination et au delà de ces cinq
service minimum il nous faut construire
cette médecine qui sera tourné vers le
patient et qui lui permettra qui
permettra pardon de construire son
parcours dans le système de santé et à
chaque instant de le protéger au mieux
je ne veux pas ici m'exprimer sur des
travaux qui ne sont pas totalement
abouti la ministre poursuit d'ailleurs
les concertations et nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir à l'été et je
m'exprimerai à l'été à l'issue de
l'ensemble de ces concertations
vous aurez aussi votre part de
responsabilité à prendre
mesdames et messieurs dans la
transformation du système de santé
le rôle des assurances complémentaires
ne se limite pas toujours au
remboursement des soins
vous êtes vous-même des offreurs de
santé pas seulement des payeurs et donc
vous connaissez l'intimité si je puis
dire de la complexité que je viens de
rappeler des services de soins au centre
de santé en passant par les ehpad et
l'esprit mutualiste s'est aussi
d'aider à construire des parcours de
soins sur les territoires parfois les
plus isolés au profit des patients les
plus vulnérables d'investir dans la
prévention de coopérer avec les
professionnels au fond vous avez dans
vos gènes une part des réponses que nous
souhaitons apporter à ce défi
contemporain et donc vous le voyez bien
sur ce sujet nous aurons à l'été à
prendre position là aussi sur une
transformation en profondeur qui n'est
pas simplement un sujet monétaire mais
qui impliquera une réorganisation
profonde et qui impliquera aussi de
revoir l'ensemble des structures
auxquelles nous nous sommes habitués
depuis dix ans de la tarification à
l'acte à la tarification à l'activité de
la sacro-sainte summa divisio entre une
médecine de ville et une médecine
hospitalière et il faudra là aussi
revenir sur des habitudes pour que
l'ensemble de celles et ceux qui
apportent le soin puisse prendre toutes
leurs responsabilités
la réponse au deuxième défi qu'est le
vieillissement et ce serait sur ce point
plus rapide
elle était là aussi indispensable vous
l'avez évoqué pour le premier point qui
m'importe celui de prévenir nous devons
et ce sera au coeur du système de
retraite qui est en train d'être
construits sous l'autorité de la
ministre et dans la concertation est en
cours nous devons mieux prévenir et donc
tout au long de la vie inciter les
employeurs inciter l'ensemble de la
collectivité
là aussi à prévenir pour que chacun
puisse mieux vieillir et que les
inégalités soient progressivement lycée
devant le grand âge et il nous faut
prendre en compte l'ensemble des
disparités dans le système de retraite
tel que nous sommes en train de le
construire
il faut ensuite apporter les réponses de
solidarité non négociable c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui avait fait l'objet de
mon engagement pour le minimum
vieillesse
qui a augmenté de 30 euros par mois au
1er avril dernier et qui augmentera au
1er janvier prochain de 30 euros
et j'entends murmuré dans la salle rares
sont les personnes au minimum vieillesse
qui paye la csg à taux plein donc ce
sont des gens qui n'ont fait que gagner
du pouvoir d'achat sur non mais c'est
une réalité
mais c'est une réalité c'est important
de ne pas laisser s'installer des des
malentendus toutes personnes au minimum
vieillesse ou qui a une retraite modeste
paye une csg ce qui est tout à fait
normal et le choix était de ne pas la
bouche et qui est une csg au taux réduit
voudrais pas laisser penser que gens
dont on a augmenté le minimum vieillesse
continuer auront une csg qui aurait
augmenté sur le grand âge
la réponse est donc sur la retraite la
réponse c'est évidemment la refonte
d'ensemble de notre système de retraite
avec des principes que je veux là aussi
clair et simple je veux que nous
puissions maintenir notre système de
retraite par répartition et la
solidarité entre les générations
c'est le choix qui a été fait
c'est le choix qui a été fait sur lequel
je me suis engagé et c'est le
solidarisme qui est au coeur de notre
république
simplement ce solidarisme complet il va
aussi avec la fin d'une société de
statut et donc il va vers un système que
nous sommes en train de construire de
négocier de concerter qui permettra
qu'un euro cotisé donne le même montant
de droit et donc que nous fassions
progressivement converger l'ensemble des
régimes existants qui s'étaient
construits dans des différences
aujourd'hui devenu inexplicable c'est la
clé pour rétablir quoi d'une part la
justice du système dans la durée en
ayant une période de transition que nous
assumons et de permettre aussi la
confiance dans le système pour que
chacun puisse de manière lisible
immédiate connaître ses droits et pour
qu'ils sachent que ses droits à un euro
cotisé sont les mêmes que celui du
voisin
c'est la clé pour répondre à la défiance
collective dans laquelle nous nous
sommes installés et aussi pour répondre
au défi du vieillissement que je
rappelais il y un instant sur ce sujet
une loi sera présenté au début de
l'année 2019 et sera votée dans le
premier semestre de l'année 2019
les décisions seront prises elles seront
claires un temps de transition sera
ensuite accordé et nous avons choisi au
fond de ne pas faire une énième réforme
budgétaire privilégiant le court terme
pour enfin faire la réforme qui permet
de remettre à plat l'édifice rejeté la
confiance et la justice en acceptant une
transition longue mais vous avez
parfaitement raison c'est une somme dans
une salle d'interpellations libre mais
j'aime cela
sur ce sujet sur ce sujet vous avez
parfaitement raison il ne faut ni
oublier les femmes ni oublier les
carrières brisées est fracturée n'est
oublié les femmes et les hommes vivent
en situation de handicap n'est oublié
aussi les situations de grande
difficulté et les inégalités face aux
risques sociaux professionnels et donc
c'est aussi tout cela que système
transparent va intégrer dans les
paramètres et qui seront de manière
transparente concertée négocier et voté
par le parlement
vous avez donc parfaitement raison enfin
sur le grand âge il était évident que
nous ne pouvons plus longtemps différées
la réponse à apporter en matière de
dépendance
j'évoquais tout à l'heure la réalité le
quotidien pour nombre de nos concitoyens
pour les personnels soignants pour
celles et ceux qui partagent ces
réalités souvent dramatiques
nous avons sur ce point besoin là aussi
tout en prévenant mieux de mobiliser
l'ensemble des acteurs de reconnaître la
part de la solidarité familiale et de
lui donner un statut et une place la
part de la solidarité collective sociale
d'en construire enfin les mécanismes
responsables de financement et enfin
d'accepter d'avoir le débat national
indispensable qui permettra de répondre
à ce nouveau risque qui est là et auquel
il nous faut donc répondre
nous en connaissons les évaluations
première 9 à 10 milliards d'euros nous
disent certains nous savons aussi que la
réponse c'est dans une mobilisation de
l'ensemble des acteurs
c'est dans l'innovation c'est dans la
capacité à donner une place dans la
société et à mieux reconnaître et
rémunérer le travail de celles et ceux
qui accompagnent les personnes
dépendantes et d'assurer la
transformation des établissements en
établissement plus médicalisée qu'ils ne
le sont aujourd'hui
cette grande transformation
elle ne sera pas là non plus du jour au
lendemain la ministre a apporté il ya
quelques semaines des premières réponses
indispensables et d'urgence je sais
qu'elle ne réponde pas totalement à la
souffrance que vivent celles et ceux qui
travaillent dans ces établissements je
sais qu'elle ne réponde pas totalement à
l'indignation légitime de nombre dans
notre de nos concitoyens nous ne
réglerons pas du jour au lendemain je ne
vais pas vous faire de promesse à
l'emporte-pièce de promesses d'estrade
et ce n'est pas simplement un engagement
financier
il sera au rendez vous parce qu'il nous
faut investir sur ce sujet non il nous
faut construire un nouveau risque
il nous faut répondre à cette nouvelle
vulnérabilité sociale qu'est la
dépendance sur ce sujet l'année 2019
sera aussi consacrée à une loi qui sera
votée avant la fin d'année
enfin
enfin j'ai parlé de ce troisième défi et
l exclusion la grande pauvreté dans
laquelle notre société
non parce est installé mais laquelle
c'est parfois trop habitués et qui doit
continuer à nous indigner sur ce sujet
comment devons-nous progressivement
transformer les choses là aussi une
concertation est en cours qui m'amènera
à m'exprimer dans les semaines à venir
et qui sous l'autorité de la ministre a
impliqué d'ailleurs nombre d'entre vous
autour d'une stratégie pauvreté mais
c'est l'ensemble du gouvernement qui est
mobilisée pour repenser notre
organisation collective notre solidarité
nationale j'entends tous les débats qui
ont agité les dernières semaines aussi
vrai que la réponse à la pauvreté ne
serait être monétaire
les solutions que nous devons apporter
au problème ne serait être budgétaire
c'est dans la transformation d'ensemble
de la prévention de l'accompagnement et
de la responsabilisation que nous devons
lutter contre ce fléau
prévenir c'est notre premier combat face
à l'exclusion et la pauvreté
et là-dessus la bataille c'est
évidemment l'école nous avons avec
l'obligation de scolarisation des trois
ans avec le dédoublement du nombre
d'élèves par classe dans les zones les
plus difficiles avec l'investissement
scolaire avec la méritocratie à l'école
à chaque étape de la vie y compris dans
l'orientation et l'accès au premier
cycle
c'est la fin de l'assignation à
résidence les fruits irons avec le temps
et les enfants qui grandissent mais
c'est la fin d'un système qui a continué
à signer à être déterministe parce que
vous étés les lettrisme à l'école dans
les endroits les plus pauvres où étaient
les endroits où les enfants n'allaient
pas la maternelle où il n'y avait qu'un
peu dans les quartiers les plus modestes
où étaient les endroits où on n'avait
pas accès à l'université ou par tirage
au sort dans les familles qui n'était
pas conseiller pas orienté
et donc l'école forme et c'est la
première réponse pour prévenir prévenir
s'est aussi accompagnée éviter que les
villes ne décroche que la vulnérabilité
lorsqu'elles s'installent au travail ne
soit plus grave encore et c'est le sujet
des familles monoparentales absolument
fondamental sur lequel nous reviendrons
dans le cadre de la stratégie pauvreté
mais sur lequel ici je veux redire que
la décision consistant à prendre une
augmentation de 30% de l'aide à la garde
d'enfant pour les familles
monoparentales 7 un acte de prévention
de la pauvreté c'est éviter que des
femmes ou des hommes et bien souvent ce
sont des femmes seules parce qu'ils sont
déjà vulnérables parce qu'ils ont un
enfant ne peuvent pas reprendre un
travail ou garder leur travail parce
qu'ils ne peuvent pas garder faire
garder leurs enfants ou qui n'ont pas
les moyens de le faire garder cette
réponse apportée votée par les
parlementaires à l'automne dernier est
en vigueur depuis le 1er janvier
c'est un début de réponse et il sera
complété par la stratégie pauvreté la
prévention est là aussi une bataille
essentielle indispensable ensuite il
nous faut là aussi à fumer
la solidarité collective pour les plus
fragiles et les plus vulnérables il nous
faut assumer des dépenses sociales qui
accompagnent celles et ceux ci ne
peuvent n'arrive pas à revenir vers le
travail et sont par des accidents de la
vie ou des accidents physique a signé
dans cette situation sur ce sujet nos
engagements monétaires non seulement
seront maintenues mais ils doivent être
complétés complété par quoi par de
l'accompagnement
il nous faut là aussi pour les plus
vulnérables de la société qui sont à
chaque fois des
vie particulière des parcours
individuels l'épaisseur et la brutalité
d'existence qu'on ne saurait réduire
dans des chiffres ou dans des cases il
nous faut aussi apporter de
l'accompagnement de la présence il a
fait notre échec
je le dis en toute franchise nous avons
pensé qu'en donnant des prestations
sociales en ayant des gens qu'on
appelait des bénéficiaires ont répondu à
tout ça n'est pas vrai d'abord parce que
les plus fragiles d'entre eux ce sont
ceux bien souvent qu'ils ne vont pas
chercher ces aides
parce qu'ils ne savent pas parce qu'on
ne les a pas accompagner parce que la
fatigue les morsures de la vie sont
telles qu à un moment donné on n'a même
plus le courage d'aller chercher et donc
nous devons assumer
sur cette part de l'exclusion sur ces
vies les plus fragilisés les plus brisé
d'avoir un accompagnement social et là
dessus dit il existe je ne mésestime pas
le rôle formidable que jouent les
travailleurs sociaux
nombre d'associations mais nous devons
davantage de reconnaître
l'institutionnaliser non pas pour dire
que c'est l'état qui devrait le prendre
mais pour dire qu'on doit le reconnaître
mieux le rémunérer et lui donner une
place dans la société
il faut reconnaître que là au delà aussi
la grande exclusion a besoin d'une part
de soins de soins humains d'attention de
précaution il ya ensuite la part de
celles et ceux qui peuvent revenir vers
le travail mais que rien n'incite ni
n'accompagne pour faire ce chemin et
c'est là où il nous faut tout à la fois
accompagné et responsabiliser et
j'assume ce double discours à la fois
c'est en même temps il y à celles et
ceux qui étant minima sociaux y reste
parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas reprendre un
emploi à temps plein pour des raisons
familiales pour des raisons d'
accompagnement de même où du reste de la
famille et pour lesquelles allaient vers
quelques heures de travail allait avec
un accompagnement social vers le travail
est la bonne réponse
ce que fait par exemple la fondation
abbé pierre ou plusieurs autres acteurs
sur le terrain
ce que font plusieurs collectivités
territoriales en expérimentant ses
méthodes
c'est ce dont nous avons besoin c'est un
accompagnement utile qui permet d'aider
celui ou celle qui est dans une
situation d'exclusion à faire ce chemin
et c'est donc d'assumer que la réponse
là aussi n'est pas simplement monétaire
mais elle et de l'accompagnement qui
permet de retourner à la dignité dans et
par le travail
même si c'est un travail adapté pour les
personnes vivant en situation de
handicap que nous devons davantage
ramener vers le travail et qui le
souhaitent ou si c'est un travail
aménagé pour les plus fragiles les plus
meurtries qui ne seraient reprendre un
travail à temps plein dans un univers
professionnel sans être aidé ou
accompagné et cet accompagnement va avec
une responsabilisation va aussi avec un
contrôle va avec un suivi parce qu'ils
existent
vous avez eu raison de rappeler qu'elles
ne sont pas majoritaires mais des
situations où des gens se sont installés
dans une forme d'exclusion mais où ils
ont construit leur existence et ou dans
les situations économiques où nous
sommes nous devons là aussi les
accompagner les responsabiliser et les
faire leur faire retrouver le travail
parce qu'ils en sont capables
parce que par ce truchement ils
retrouveront leur dignité pleine et
entière parce que par ce chemin
ils aideront aussi la collectivité à
dépenser son argent vers les plus
véritablement vulnérables et nous devons
assumer ce discours qui est un discours
d'accompagnement et de
responsabilisation qui doit lui aussi
transformé nos politiques sociales et
donc il nous faut faire non seulement
sur le rsa mais sur toutes les
politiques d'accompagnement des exclus
des plus modestes d'entre nous qu'elles
soient nationales qu'elles soient
locales
d'abord un travail de synthèse et de
transparence mais ensuite également ce
travail qui permettra de faire le chemin
inverse de celui que nous avons fait
durant les dix dernières années et
d'avoir non pas une diminution de plus
de 60% de l'accompagnement pour
le rsa oubliant l'engagement d'insertion
qui allait avec la belle promesse du rmi
et un doublement du montant des
allocations versées
c'est le chemin inverse qui nous faut
investir davantage dans les personnes
les accompagnent pour qu'elles
reprennent leur dignité à chaque instant
où elles le peuvent et accompagner
toutes celles et ceux qui peuvent
revenir dans le travail vers celui parce
que l'émancipation se construit par le
travail dès qu'on ne peut il y aura
toujours celles et ceux qui ne le
peuvent pas nous devons les protéger et
être là et prendre soin d'eux et
reconnaître leur part dans notre société
mais que toutes celles et ceux qui le
peuvent soit accompagnée pour le faire
et permettre que nos politiques
publiques que notre engagement collectif
que votre engagement aussi soit ce
chemin d'accompagnement et de
responsabilisation qui permet
l'émancipation dans et par le travail
parce que si toutes celles et ceux qui
peuvent faire ce chemin ne le font pas
nous n'aurons pas légitimement les
moyens d'aller financer les risques
légitime et la grande vulnérabilité que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure ça n'est pas
vrai et nous devons aussi regarder cela
en face parce que sinon nous nous mentir
ion et que toutes celles et ceux qui ne
voudraient rien changé qui considère qu
en quelque sorte la frontière
technologique de la justice sociale ce
serait dépensé plus en responsabilisant
personnes me disent qu'ils financent à
la fin toujours quelqu'un vous ou vos
enfants ou ceux qui ne sont pas encore
nés et donc faisons ce travail de
transformation
là aussi de notre politique sociale en
apportant cet accompagnement en
transformant aussi cette place du
travail social est à mes yeux cette
transformation est indispensable si nous
voulons réussir ce chemin que j'évoque
et c'est aussi pour cela que ce que nous
sommes en train de faire pour permettre
cette émancipation
c'est de construire à chaque étape de la
vie les nouvelles sécurité individuelle
et nouvelle sécurité ne sont plus de
statut ça n'est plus dans la société de
demain ni le chemin h tel qu'il existait
ni le rsa c'est la possibilité à chaque
instant de la vie d'êtres reformer
réorienter d'être tout à la fois
protéger et accompagner pour pouvoir à
chaque instant s'émanciper par ce
travail le coeur de la loi qui arrive en
ce moment au parlement sur la
transformation de l'apprentissage et de
la formation professionnelle c'est cela
et c'est un continuum de la grande
pauvreté
jusqu'à la vie tout au long du travail
ce qu'il nous faut faire c'est
réinvestir dans la personne sait
accompagner davantage s'est
responsabilisé plus et non pas
considérer que la seule réponse c'est
l'argent de la collectivité pour des
situations personnelles devenu un
personnel il nous faut sortir sur tous
ces sujets d'une logique de guichet pour
une logique d'accompagnement
voilà mesdames et messieurs ce que je
voulais vous dire sur ces trois défis je
reviendrai dans les mois qui viennent à
la fois sur la pauvreté et sur la santé
mais j'assume pleinement ce discours de
vérité de responsabilité collective qui
fait qu'à mes yeux les réponses à nos
défis contemporains ne peuvent être les
solutions d'hier car elles n'ont pas
répondu à ces défis et car elles ont
conduit à quoi à dépenser toujours plus
en répondant à chaque fois un peu moins
à la réalité quotidienne
ce que je veux qu'ensemble nous
puissions rebâtir inspiré des valeurs
profondes qui sont les vôtres qui sont
celles de la république qui sont celles
de l'esprit 35 c'est de regarder en face
à société qui est la nôtre une société
faite de ruptures de grandes
transformations de grande inquiétude de
ce vieillissement que nous avons
longuement évoqué l'un et l'autre pour
que le coeur de notre réponse soit de
mieux prévenir soit de réhumaniser et
d'accompagner non pas pour aider à vivre
dans la maladie ou à vivre dans la
pauvreté
mais pour aider à sortir de la maladie
et à sortir de la pauvreté et permettre
de responsabiliser l'ensemble des
acteurs
de faire que chacun dans cette société
ne doit être traité comme étant en état
de minorités sociales intellectuelles
mais que chacun a une part de la
solution
donc oui monsieur le président pour
réussir cette transformation
je ne pense pas une seule seconde que
l'état puisse y arriver seul je pense
profondément que cette transformation
sera maintenant une question de
décisions d'actes de détail sera un
travail de tâcheron du quotidien où
l'état devront croire devra prendre sa
part de responsabilité mais où
l'ensemble des acteurs qui font la
solidarité nationale devront apprendre à
réinventer leur rôle pour penser ces
défis et participer à cette
transformation de cela je vous sais
capable de cela je ne sais capable vive
la république et vive la france
[Applaudissements]